if you're looking to a politician for
how you're gonna get your your your
sustenance in the future forget it hi
I'm Ted baliker with reason TV and today
I'll be speaking with Michael Koval
Covell is a best-selling financial
author and director of the new
documentary broke the new American Dream
so Michael why did you make this film
somebody had to make it but there have
been plenty of documentaries already
about the financial crisis why not why
there's been documentaries that have
been blamed somebody or give somebody an
excuse there hasn't been a documentary
where somebody actually says hey that's
what this is what happened and we all
have to take responsibility and here's a
way out and I like how your documentary
did just that zeroed in on the
individual what is your big-picture
advice to the one guy watching it cut
your losses I mean if you make a bad
investment get out but people don't like
to do that you've a lot of the film goes
into why why buy and hold is a bad idea
why is that a bad idea it's a strategy
buy it holds just a strategy it's saying
this is how I'm going to trade the
markets and if you're using a trading
strategy that doesn't make money after a
dozen years you have to say to yourself
well maybe if I hold on for another
dozen it will work or you have to
reassess and say is this really a good
strategy what do you hope will really
stick with the viewer politicians do not
care about you politicians exist for one
reason one reason to sit in a chair but
they they want to sit in a chair because
that chair gives them power and so when
they come on TV and they tell you that
they care about you and they want to
help you etc etc etc know when the
camera goes off they talk to their aides
about what the polls are and how they
can keep power and whether they get
reelected etc etc either they groove off
that and they're making very its
political decisions and short-term
political decisions exactly well their
short-term political decisions just to
keep getting elected and so that's it
that's a real a huge issues to get
people to understand that politicians
are not your daddy you know and if you
think they are well you're probably
broke by the time you know retire and
you will be one of those people that you
know you're looking around during
retirement ages your chief
me today how about cat food if you're
looking to a politician for how you're
gonna get your your your sustenance in
the future forget it nowadays after you
know we've had this big downturn people
are more confused than ever
what what do you say to someone who's
who's just overwhelmed by all the noise
on both sides what what could you say to
that person to start to write his own
financial ship if I'm advising somebody
and you're really being brutally honest
with somebody you say look you gotta
take a step back perhaps you did
everything wrong you know you put no
money down you bought a condo you lost
rear end but now you've got to do
something different and you got to take
a step back and you got to say okay I
got to go back to like when I was a
little kid running a lemonade stand
I put the lemonade stand up if someone
buys something from me I make money if
they don't I lose money alright you know
I don't make any money
and you got to get back to the basics I
mean life is really pretty simple you
know you produce you get rewarded for it
if you don't produce you don't get
rewarded for it and occasionally these
crazy bubble times happen where
everybody feels like they're getting you
know money coming from heaven but that's
usually fleeting mentioned the role of
government you've mentioned that
government is not your daddy what and
the government is one of the main
villains in your film what specifically
did the folks in Washington do wrong
well first off I don't answer that
question I take a step back how did we
get to the point in 2010 where we are
today and I say it starts with one thing
it starts with Netscape going public in
the summer of 1995 and that created a
euphoria that probably this country had
not seen for decades upon decades and
that euphoria created what we all know
now as the dot-com bubble and the bubble
did not last and it popped in the spring
of 2000 and when that bubble popped in
the spring of 2000 my perspective the
powers that be whether it's politicians
the Fed etc they said you know what
we've got to save the Dow we've got to
save the Dow and they dropped they
dropped interest rates down to 1% I
guess in the bottom down in the spring
of tho 3 and getting rates down to 1%
did something it created another bubble
created the role estate bubble and so
when you you look at these things you
say we'll get
what do politicians do wrong you know
there it is they they rigged the market
they rigged it and they rigged it
through interest rate manipulation and
that interest rate manipulation created
I mean the interest rate manipulation
that came after the.com bubble created
another problem and we're paying for it
still today so I argued I'll start with
Netscape you're also very tough on the
media in your documentary what role did
the media play in getting us into this
mess these cheerleaders I mean seriously
I mean if you turn on CNBC in the
morning and you say hey yeah I'm gonna
make some money today let's see what
let's see if Bart arelma and Kramer have
to say I mean really I mean you and I
know some of the traders in this planet
that do exceptionally well and they do
not turn on CNBC in the morning and go
what is mark Haines have to say you know
so at the end of the day CNBC is a
business and it's a very successful
business they make a lot of money and
the business is for you to turn on and
watch and watch the advertisements they
call it they come across the screen and
that's how they make money
but that has nothing to do with you
making money and Jim Cramer is a guy
that you zero in on in particular one
interesting point in your movie is that
when he mentioned a stock the next day
it would have his mentioning the stock
would have a sizable impact on that
stock price correct right barons had
done some research and they had looked
at it I think it was like on average
like two percent boost and it didn't
necessarily last but it showed that
there are a lot of people that you know
they're sitting there at their house
they're like oh my gosh you know I don't
know how to make money I don't know what
to do and this guy Kramer they they say
you run out they said you know he ran a
really successful hedge fund and you
know he's kind of loud and crazy and hey
he says to buy something today and I
guess I should buy it well is what's the
difference between that and going to
Vegas and you know ponying it up at
Mandalay Bay and going to the craps
table it's the same thing you mentioned
gambling one of the one of the most
interesting parts about your film I
think was the the time you took to
compare the lottery to poker you have
some famous poker players in there as
well can you talk about battle I'm
pretty passionate about that
I mean I look at it really that it's
it's it's one of the things that we
really have trouble with the society is
math in numbers how do we look at
numbers in math and the government these
people that say they're gonna help us
they're in charge of this big scam
called the lottery which is designed to
take money from poor people's pockets
and you know I think what the numbers
take it's like thirty five percent or
some number like forty percent of people
that make under 35 K believe the lottery
is their best chance to get a half
million dollars for retirement
that's all that's that's sad that's
really sad that was organized by a
government everybody's trying to make
sense of the financial downturn and
decide you know aha
this is what caused it we had two
bubbles back to back the.com bubble in
the real-estate bubble and we can think
of every sophisticated explanation but
people wanted to get rich fast and then
the hundred year flood where these
things burst actually happens every
three to four years it's not just like
you know we these these situations
happen they have been more regularly
than we think I mean I think the only
public policy that we could work that I
really put my I say hey that was really
at least for the real estate bubble was
the lowering of interest rates is that
really there's no doubt in my mind that
that created the euphoria that was the
gasoline do you think we're going to
learn from our mistakes have you look
into the future I've good course not
what are we gonna learn we're not
learning anything I mean I think they
released a bunch of programs today
supposed that's going to keep real
estate floating on air even further and
you know whatever that you know you hope
one day they may be real estate will
find its natural floor whatever that is
or perhaps the Dow will find its natural
floor but no we're not good I don't
think we're gonna learn anything I mean
I hope we do but there's too many people
that there's too many people that that
you know they don't want to because it's
hard work it's hard work to know what's
going on it's hard work to understand
what some of the great investors do what
some of the great poker players do that
takes time and effort it's much easier
that if you know the leader of the free
world stands up in a podium on Labor Day
and and
he's gonna give everyone goodies and
there's a bunch of people standing
behind him smiling that's much easier
for a lot of people and I'm not I'm not
look I'm not pointing to the right or
the left I'm saying from my standpoint
most politicians really add zero value